you know i hate it when i'm right about
horrible things i really do
but americans are now the dangerous
disease caring
foreigners just like i predicted we
would be some months ago and i hate it
i'm not happy about this i'm not
gloating about this it
personally upsets me that this is the
reality much of the world at least for
now
is safely returning to normality
friends in belgium france a lot of
different places
masks required on public transit uh
things are more spaced out at
restaurants but
increasingly a normal existence is
resuming in countries that have
successfully fought the virus
that is not the case in the united
states we
are not allowed to go to many parts of
the world the travel bans
which we are known for are now against
us
because coronavirus is raging here the
american right wing
is all about banning others but it is we
who are now banned because we are the
danger visitors from 15 different
countries
can now go to the european union not
americans
it's too dangerous there's too much
coronavirus here we've failed we are
on a list so to speak the american right
has been demonizing others as those who
like tucker carlson said on his fox news
program some months ago
immigrants make our country dirtier and
poorer that was tucker carlson well
the american right has said it's
foreigners who bring disease the
american right has said we need to stop
them from coming here but now we are the
ones that are too risky
for other countries to let us in as
erica lee writes in a washington post
piece
there's a very long history of tying
foreigners to disease here in the united
states you go back to
the 1700s germans and yellow fever
they were going to bring yellow fever
irish in the 1800s they were going to
bring cholera
so many examples chinese immigrants
smallpox and bubonic plague and leprosy
jews and tuberculosis that's a classic
italians and polio
in the early 1900s mexicans to
plague typhus and smallpox
it's a very long list and the links
between xenophobia and disease are
widespread
they're long lasting and we've seen much
of the same
more recently with coronavirus and so
understand that chinese flu wuhan flu
kung flu as donald trump has repeatedly
called it all of that stuff
it's just more of the same this is not
new we've seen this in the u.s since the
1700s
and of course yeah the virus originated
in china and yeah china lied and yes
china should be held accountable
but every country dealt with a virus
that originated in china
most countries dealt with that virus
that originated in china far better
than we did so much better in fact that
we are now banned for many of those
countries
it's an embarrassment the virus is
exploding in huge parts of this country
again a single day case record yesterday
i will talk to you later on by the way
texas now two days in a row setting its
single day case uh death record
exactly as we would have predicted when
cases started surging
in mid to late june this has nothing to
do
with immigration it has to do with a
late and terrible testing program
lack of a contact tracing program
botched and too early reopenings
reluctance to wear masks in some states
and it's now bleeding into the
responsible states too i've been saying
for several weeks now
we're doing great here in massachusetts
but it can't last forever when cases are
so high in so many of these other states
and indeed cases and hospitalizations
are starting to trickle up here in
massachusetts it's only a little bit but
it's starting to happen
we are now the disease-caring foreigners
that have to be banned from other
countries and it's embarrassing and it's
horrifying and i hate it
but i understand why countries have to
do it is our weakness
ego is our weakness anti-science
sentiment
is it hyper polarization we won't ever
be like those other countries many of us
believed it won't ever come to that and
now coronavirus has shown
that we were so extraordinarily
unprepared
and had failed leadership so now the
question is what do we do
do we need another lockdown do we need
like a six-week
coordinated full lockdown if that's what
we need it's never going to happen i
mean
you know i'm talking about you really
you don't leave your house without a
mask
you really don't go anywhere other than
for for essential trips grocery store
or whatever the case may be and you'd
have to do new stimulus payments like
is that what we actually need now
because when you look at ten thousand
cases a day in florida
ten thousand cases a day in texas you
don't
get that under control by saying let's
just not go to bars
let's not do indoor dining you just
don't that's not how you get it under
control
clearly the summer heat isn't stopping
it clearly it's just not going to
disappear
in april the way donald trump and so
many others said we are nowhere near
heard immunity
but no matter what happens on that front
you've got to be registered to vote and
we have to remove this administration in
november because no matter what happens
between now and november 3rd
we need someone else at the helm that
must happen and so
we're going to talk about polling a
little later let's not
take our eye off the ball when it comes
to acting responsibly day-to-day on
coronavirus
let's do it and encourage everybody we
know to do it but when it comes to
removing this failed leader not really
really even a leader we've got to not
lose sight of that and that's coming up
just just four months from now tuesday
we will be having the third
ever david pakman show chess tournament
you can register for free at
davidpakman.com
chess hope you'll join us we'll also
have a big one-day membership special on
tuesday july 14th you can be notified
about that
simply by signing up for my newsletter
at davidpakman.com
let me know what's going on in your
state i'm on twitter
at d pacman